Vsauce! Kevin here, and there’s a secret
message hidden in these 144 characters -- that’s
a 12x12 square grid and every card has its
own coordinates. A dozen dozen, a gross. I’m
gonna decode the message randomly using dice
to choose which cards I’ll turn over, and
I guarantee it will work perfectly in only
11 choices, no matter what they are -- then
I will show you how to do this with any message
of any length. Even an entire randomly-rolled
book.
Here’s the setup. The grid has X and Y axes
numbered 1 through 12, so the very bottom
left card is at (1, 1) and the top right card
is at (12, 12). I have two 12-sided dice.
One rolls for X, one rolls for Y. There’s
an equal probability of rolling everything
from a 1 to a 12. We can’t just use two
normal 6-sided dice to add up to 12, because
we’d have a probability bell curve peaking
around 7 and it is literally impossible to
roll a 1 with 2 d6 dice.
Alright, here we go. Roll number one. Our
game begins. Okay, I got (3, 11), alright
so I’m gonna mark that card with a big X
and then I’ll remove all the cards above
it, below it, to the left, and to the right
-- we’re wiping out everything that shares
an X or a Y value with each roll.
GOT IT?
Let’s continue Roll number two -- (7, 6).
Alright, (7,6) right here. Same thing, mark
it with an X, wipe out the column and row.
I’m gonna keep playing, and if I roll a
number that corresponds to a missing coordinate,
like (5,6) which is now blank, I’ll just
re-roll until I get a hit.
LISTEN. AT THIS POINT THERE’S SOMETHING
YOU NEED TO KNOW. DESPERATELY.
I’m only rolling dice so that you know I’m
choosing cards randomly. But when you play
this with someone, you don’t need dice,
just ask the other person to choose whatever
cards they want. They’ll keep choosing until
there’s only one card left without an X,
and you’ll reveal the perfectly-decoded
message. And they’ll freak out. Since they’re
the ones choosing, they can be sure it’s
not rigged.
More on that later -- for now let’s 80’s
action movie montage the rest of my rolls.
Alright there’s only one blank card left
so that gets our final X. All of our selected
coordinates are listed here on the left. I’m
gonna put all of the cards in a row so that
you can read them easily when I flip them
over.
WAIT. How is this even possible? I put letters
on 144 cards, I randomly choose 12 of them,
and I’m left with exactly the 12 cards I
want in exactly the correct order? There’s
no way this is gonna work -- RIGHT?
W...WR...WRON…. Exclamation point. WRONG!
Because this is a variation on the Magic Square
discovered by Chinese mathematicians 2,200
years ago and tweaked a lot later by Canadian
postman and magician Stewart James. In a Magic
Square, adding up each row, column, and diagonal
gives you the same total, called the Magic
Constant. The number of rows and columns is
called the order. So this is a simple Order
3 Magic Square with a Magic Constant of 15.
That’s not too hard for us now, it’s a
little like sodoku -- but it took another
800 years for Varahamihira to decipher the
first 16-block Order 4 Magic Square in India.
And 1,000 years after THAT, we knew there
are 880 distinctly different Magic Squares
of Order 4.
Now we have pandiagonal magic squares, multimagic
squares, methods for creating magic squares
of odd orders and even orders, and they’re
so complex that even Euler’s hypotheses
on constructing evenly odd ordered mutually
orthogonal Graeco-Latin squares turned out
to be wrong.
But the one magic square that has fascinated
for centuries, even outside the math community,
is stuck in the background of an early-16th
century German engraving. Albrecht Dürer’s
“Melancolia I” depicts a winged woman
who represents either melancholy and depression
or geometry, depending on who you ask. She’s
surrounded by all sorts of hand tools, an
hourglass, a compass, a dog... A dog is not
a hand tool. A dog is your best friend. And
way in the back corner is a very unique magic
square.
Dürer’s magic square isn’t technically
his -- it appears in Luca Pacioli’s “De
Viribus Quantitatis” about 15 years before
the engraving. Pacioli was Leonardo da Vinci’s
teacher and best friend, and the odds that
Dürer coincidentally came up with the same
one on his own are astronomical. The magic
constant in Dürer’s order 4 magic square
is 34 -- but the magic comes by more than
just adding rows, columns, and diagonals.
You can do each of the four quadrants to get
34. The 4 blocks in the center? 34. The outside
4 corners? 34.
Inner rectangles, 34. Diagonal rhombuses,
34. The internal 3x3 blocks, 34.
Vertical X? 34 and 34. Horizontal X? 34 and
34. Trapezoids, 34. Squares that don’t use
the corners? 34.
When you sort and stack just the right combination
of numbers, really incredible patterns happen
-- and it’s the same with words. The classical
example is the SATOR or ROTAS square found
in Pompeii and through Europe. The palindrome
TENET in the middle of the SATOR square? That’s
where Christopher Nolan’s movie title came
from. Tenet. Puzzlemakers have successfully
made magic word squares up to order 9, but
a true order 10 word square is still considered
the Holy Grail of recreational linguistics.
I did a modified magic square with 12, and
I said you could do it even with a book of
any length. Look, here’s the mind-blowingly
simple secret -- you just need to repeat your
hidden message on as many rows as there are
characters in the word, message, or passage.
Hello is [H E L L O five times stacked]. You
can do Happy Birthday for someone. It'd just
be 14 rows including the space. You could
randomly re-create the entire Harry Potter
series, you’d just need… about a 5,327,000
x 5,327,000 grid of the book start to finish,
with a full book on each row, assuming the
series’ 1,084,170 words conform to an average
word length of 4.7 characters and there’s
a space in between each one. And how many
choices would it take? If however many rows
or columns is equal to n, then it’ll take
n-1 choices, every single time.
No matter how big your mystery grid is, every
time you make a selection and remove all the
other cards on that selection’s X and Y
planes, you eliminate possible duplicates
and isolate that choice as being the only
letter that can occupy that specific position
in the column or row.
It’s weirdly simple. It’s weirdly complex.
It’s elegant and amazing in a strange combination
of mathematical beauty and linguistics.
And you can grab a marker and some slips of
paper and play this secret message game to
reveal something monumental -- like proposing
to spend the rest of your life with your significant
other (MARRY ME?).
Or... get someone to unwittingly spell the
word “BUTT”
And as always, thanks for watching.
Hey! The Curiosity Box by Vsauce is celebrating
its five-year anniversary. That’s five years
of delivering brain food right to your door.
And it’s time for you to join us. So to
get yourself or someone else the gift of smart,
go to CuriosityBox.com. Join our brains. Join
our br...